samuel samuel
j'ai quelques questions à te poser ses
lèvres de ski c'est sur les leaders de
demain
ces volets nouveau je vous souhaite
bonne chance vous en aurez besoin
gros c'est le paradis ici bonjour je
m'appelle samuel qu'est ce qu'ils disent
est revenue à garder moi ça on dirait un
ministre vient parler à petit frère ça
va aussi bossé très dur sur l'a1
quittant mais un tube ma gueule moi ces
gens ne portent jamais rien de bon
qu'est ce que tu peux me dire sur ce
trophée pourquoi on pense que ce trophée
l'arme du crime
est ce que nous sommes vraiment ce que
les autres pensent que nous sommes
[Musique]
ou est ce qu'il voit seulement notre
meilleur profil
[Musique]
je sais que parfois les apparences sont
trompeuses mais moi j'ai rien n'a bougé
[Musique]
et je veux être fier
tu vas jamais sortir à laquelle est ce
que tu m'entends quand la poudre va au
contact du feu
il ne peut y avoir qu'une conséquence
l'explosion beau
qui a fait ça à christian je sais pas
j'ai pas envie de jouer marée noire
vous avez d'autres questions posées